it's hard to imagine a president with a
worse relationship with their own staff
then the relationship Donald Trump has
with his staff demanding prison time for
former staffers calling former and even
current staffers insults and names and
now Donald Trump has forced his second
chief of staff John Kelly to resign it's
another one of these de-facto firings I
tend to think Pat that it almost doesn't
matter whether we say that John Kelly
resigned or was forced to resign or was
fired because in practice we're talking
about the same thing which is Trump's
not having it anymore although there are
people who write in and say no David you
know you should be a little more precise
about which it is because there are some
legal implications with Kelly I don't
think that those legal implications are
particularly relevant because the
reports have been that John Kelly and
Donald Trump were not even speaking
towards the end of Kelly's tenure Kelly
was brought in with the idea that he'd
clean up the riffraff and in a way he
sort of did right when Kelly came in
people like Anthony scaramouche II was
pushed out Stephen Bannen was pushed out
for example but Trump doesn't want to
sort of play it straight the way that
Kelly wants it to be played and it turns
out that it wasn't a good relationship
the rumors about the Kelly Trump
relationship imploding seemed to have
been true we learned about that shouting
match that John Kelly had with a
national security adviser John Bolton at
the White House we saw Kelly sort of
painfully grimacing as Donald Trump said
dumber and dumber things during press
events and indeed it's coming to an end
so you have a White House here that is
in chaos as Trump reflective of
reflexively is looking to find something
he can do to ease the mounting pressure
on him as a result of the various crimes
of his associates and the slowdown of
the economy and the breakdown of
relationships with our allies but then
it gets even worse Trump identified Mike
Pence's chief of staff to become his new
chief of staff his name is Nick Aires
Aires has said no thanks doesn't want
the job he's not in
imagine for a moment how bad it has to
be how bad and toxic and destructive it
must be in the Trump White House for a
36 year old who gets offered the job of
a lifetime to turn down being the
president's chief of staff he gets
offered this position and he says no I'm
actually leaving the administration
altogether at the end of the year and
I'm gonna stick with Mike Pence for the
last few weeks until then Nick's Nick
Ayers is saying in principle your
administration is such a train wreck
that I'm going to turn down what is for
most people a once-in-a-lifetime job
opportunity now there's one other
element to this Pat that some people are
pointing out which is you know it may
not be that Nick Ayers somehow made
between 10 and 50 million dollars
consulting by the time he was 34 years
old that's what he doesn't want
scrutinized if he were to become the
president's next chief of staff that may
be true for all we know Nick Ayers might
know a lot about Mike Pence's
involvement in from Prussia which is
what we were saying earlier but one way
or another he says no thanks to what for
most people would be an incredible
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity I just
think he that he doesn't want to risk
the embarrassment he doesn't want to end
up leaving the White House in a few
months and be ridiculed by the entire
country I mean that's what happens to
Sean Spicer and that's what happened to
Anthony scare Moochie certainly they
were in different roles but the exact
same thing could happen to him and he
doesn't want his reputation and all the
successes that he's had in business to
be tarnished in any case the Trump
administration is down to effectively
running job fairs to see who wants a job
at this time will Trump attack Nick
Ayers on Twitter we'll see will Trump
deny ever having offered him the job he
already did he started tweeting earlier
today it happened right before we taped
so I didn't have time to pull the tweet
but he said something like the fake news
media is saying that the pic was Nick
Aires but we actually have this great
list of people that were choosing
between or something like that I kind of
whatever Nick airs reasons are for not
taking the job I actually do understand
it if you have 12 250ml
you don't need a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar a year job or whatever
it is along with the headache and the
possible embarrassment of being involved
so front and center with this
administration I know one guy who might
be willing I think step in front of this
train wreck which is Rudy Giuliani
although I don't think his name is
actually being floated as a possible new
chief of staff and he's doing such an
amazing job defending Trump legally
anyway that I can't imagine Trump would
want to interrupt that send me your
thoughts about this followed the show on
Instagram at David Pakman show you can
follow me on Instagram at David Pakman
as well much more coming up including
the first part of my interview with
transhumanists Zoltan Istvan next one of
today's sponsors is Skillshare which is
an amazing online learning community
that offers thousands of high-quality
classes on almost any topic first 500
people who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare they've got
classes on everything from design video
editing photography business technology
cooking meditation even classes on
personal productivity I know you'll be
able to find something on Skillshare
that fascinates you or even something
that will help you in your everyday life
classes are taught by real people who
care about what they're teaching I just
took a really great class on more
advanced video editing techniques the
david pakman show is giving you two
months of free access to every class
they offer when you click the link under
this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up